There's no question that even
simple models of computers,
the models that ignore the memory
hierarchy, parallelism, and
communication have, nevertheless,
been extremely productive.
In other words,
the CS community has produced an amazing
array of applications without having to
think too hard about the physical
realities of machines.
Or so it seems.
But if we are in fact approaching
the end of Moore's Law and
as we hit new performance bottlenecks
like limits on power and energy.
Then I think you have to stop and
ask yourself the kind of basic questions
that Danny Hillis was
asking in the early 80s.
These are questions like, how do we
make the most of the machines we have?
Is there a role for physical reality and
the design of algorithms and software?
And how exactly would we do all that and
still be productive developers?
These unrelated questions are at
the frontier of HPC research.
They include wackier ideas like quantum
computing and biological computing.
These are among the main
extremes of physical computation.
Now, while our course won't go so far
as to talk about these wackier ideas,
lucky for you, there's plenty of time
afterwards for you to think about that.